well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house yeah I found that this is
so funny
remember this this is somewhere I don't
thank you seven it's like and it's like
I don't know where is that
madam Araneta right so the car is
rolling into this garage it's kind of
slowly making its way and you can tell
there's like a little bit of a speed or
something and then it's like I don't
like going on to the the guys back there
on his footboard
it's like backing up and can't tell the
guys revving it
yeah see blue man doesn't think his
phone what sorry I'm missing the funny
mirror this man just probably got his
legs broken he's in pain babe it's not
funny his legs are broken
he can't stand he's collapsing because
his legs are broken
what's up what's up like did something
he's screaming he can't look at his
concern look at his concern yes right
now it's terrible huh
you dropped something back there he just
walks away yeah it's a shitty friend
boom boom he's still on the floor and
he's writhing in pain back your hand
it looks like he dropped like a like a
business card earlier he's safer where I
thought I can't get up babe he's alright
he's not all right he's not popped up
yet
he comes up hurt later he's not look at
the title of the thing it's not even
funny it doesn't say funny anywhere I
don't know why you're laughing yeah man
gets crushed by car can't get up
paralyzed from the waist down and you're
dying of laughter oh man dude this is
why I do you think you're a serial
killer it's moments like this TV news
reported the guy's finance what it says
here hmm it does you're gonna murder me
in my sleep
Oh blue bands not laughing he's loved
you he's laughing at you right well I
figure out how your love ya are this
crease why because it's not normal
that's not funny
no at all the marrow isn't it's a guy
getting run over by a car
and you find it hilarious well yes he
goes ah ah might cuz he's in pain and
he's a foreigner he doesn't make the
same sounds in American wood and uh
again okay this oh my gosh some
settlements I go you need to tell your
therapist about this will you please
please bring this up in therapy he goes
I lost at the part where he backs up in
the dude falls on the floor lol that's a
comment underneath here um that's you
know yeah liar wow man I hope the car
isn't hurt um no don't don't try to look
for evidence to support your mental
illness you have problems well why do I
have problem because it's not it's not
supposed to be funny I don't think it's
funny that a guy got hit by a car but I
think his reaction was funny okay those
two are kind of inseparable like it's
he's reacting because he's in pain ah ha
ha ha
okay you're laughing like an
eight-year-old reactions reactions are
funny in those situations like when the
guy kills that hooker in that hangout I
can't are we done here is this done no
what's your problem what is your problem
that was funny foof I haven't laughed
that hard since the first time I saw the
video ah hi